hey I'm Conan O'Brien YouTube did some
research discovered it only takes one
minute and 34 seconds to vote it's
really that quick to save even more time
I've included a link to Google's voter
registration tools below check it out so
while you're registering I'll be here
enjoying some popcorn I put in this
microwave for a minute and 34 seconds
this is my way of illustrating that's
how quickly you can vote a minute 34
seconds and then we'll have some fresh
microwave popcorn and that's gonna be my
way of demonstrating how incredibly easy
this is and minute and 30 for coming up
and I think we are done and now it's
time for me to enjoy some amazing my
assistant usually does this for me
clearly it needed more time but I don't
let things go okay this was a terrible
idea you really need to cook popcorn
longer but the point still stands a
minute and 34 that's pretty fast and you
can help change the future of this
country
so who thought of this idea it's stupid
you should vote